ou vous la prenez votre voix comment
faites vous alors ça c'est une chose je
sais que c'est l'épreuve problèmes qui
vous intéresse c'est la voix pour moi je
déplace beaucoup ma voix mais alors tout
à fait inconsciemment parce que dès mon
plus jeune âge je peux dire que j'ai
toujours impressionner mes camarades une
quand j'étais au collège parce que même
jeu par l'âge de 12 ans je préfère une
très grosse voix et les impressionner
j'avais j'avais 12 ans je t'aime petit
bonhomme comme ça je préfère du tout là
bas qu'est ce que ça ne doit plus y voir
et légumes et l'eau était terrorisée par
ce que je pouvais déjà fait une grosse
voix comme je peux monter dans l'aigu
mais ça je suis totalement irresponsable
voir mes parents pour ça pourquoi vous
n'avez jamais travaillé justement ce
grand registre vocal
non je les fais d'abord naturellement
quand je racontais une histoire
automatiquement les voix me venaient
j'avais beau être très jeune je veux
faire une voie de vielle aure est
complètement comme ça danse ça agrémenté
mes histoires j'étais déjà un petit peu
cabot alors j'ai vraiment aimé histoire
en colorant mes personnages et je dois
dire que dans mon métier de comédien ça
m'a beaucoup servi d écho aux finances
jean moisset laisse-moi veiller sur toi
ou issus tous les s et c'est un joli
personnage qui a beaucoup plu aux
enfants d'ailleurs il y avait aussi les
aristochats il peut t'assurer qu'il
pariait a aussi brièvement y est un
personnage un peu bref comme ça et
rapide
un groupe à l'afrique est abattu peu
baveux sur les bords de chemins creux
mais pour moi c'est toujours savoureux
j'aime bien si vous étiez vraiment face
aux comédiens qui enregistre des dessins
animés
vous voyez même quelquefois des femmes
ravissante il faut dire images
épouvantables
parce qu'elle essaie de reproduire la
grimace qu'elle voit sur l'écran et dont
il me passe en effet plusieurs fois
américain vite
aaa joue du goût en europe il où il lui
arrivait de perdre aventure il y avait
également un vieux savant oui alors
qu'ils parlaient comme ça et puis comme
certains personnages qui annonce la
température du matin je savais où
étaient mes personnages m'avait inspiré
bien des deux vieux et de vieux et les
astérix et un petit personnage qui par
le sec
par toutatis par bélénos aa et comment
vous avez vous avez essayé plusieurs
avant de choisir sa bella on essaie
toujours de trouver la voie qui sort
bien alors on fait des essais
effectivement même quand une voix
originale jean tension n'a pas déjà de
la voix du étrangères alors il faut
essayer de voir ce qu'ils seront mieux
si vous avez un personnage très rond
très alors à ce polar où j'ai tout fait
proche du père tu vois beaucoup plus
graves ou des choses comme ça pour cause
assure que vous et si on a l'impression
qu'elle avoir bien du petit personnage
elle est maligne value si c'est une voix
bref qui colle avec ce petit personnage
très actifs alors on se dit tiens la
voix colle mieux à nos mister magoo
complètement farfelu très bien brillant
complètement farfelu inquiète toujours
distrait mais qui triomphent toujours le
tout les échos
populaire alors ça les ponts écroulés
oui nous sommes un peu plus d'heure vous
avez la voix populaire qui est un peu
comme ça à sa traque
comment on entend souvent d'ailleurs
voilà est carrément un autre qui
vraiment ça donne à peu près c'est la
boisson comme la leur et puis c'est vrai
qu'au bel air et madame sa séduction
dans la voix c'est quoi pour blesser
tout du cher mais ce serait de vous
faire ce que font les italiens genève
elle quand ils font les chairs mille
perles toujours tout façon très douce et
très quel est ce que vous êtes séduit à
tout à l'heure
[Musique]